Welcome back.
I don't know what
I was thinking.
Sometimes my brain
malfunctions.
But just going back to that
problem we were doing, actually
I think we should do it.
I'm a little
schizophrenic today.
So let's figure out
the equation for the
volume of a sphere.
So what's the equation?
It's x squared plus y squared
is equal to r squared.
And let's just write y as
a function of x, just so
we can do it the way we
did that last problem.
So you get y squared is equal
to r squared minus x squared.
y is equal to the square root
of r squared minus x squared.
And let's draw it.
So if this is my y-axis, this
is my x-axis, and the
equation-- draw it straight--
that's my x-axis, and then I
actually have a circle tool,
let me see if I can use it
effectively-- well,
close enough.
There you go.
I think you get the point.
But anyway.
This is just going to be the
upper half of the circle.
Actually, I should probably
just undo that circle tool
and try to draw it by hand.
So y equals the square root of
r squared minus x squared.
That's just going to be the
upper half of the circle.
So it will be the positive x
quadrant-- and then actually,
I should have drawn
the whole hemisphere.
But anyway.
Actually, let me do that,
because I think it'll
make-- edit, undo, let me
clear all of this out.
Sorry for wasting your time,
but I think it'll be effective.
OK.
So let me redraw.
So this, that's the y-axis,
that's my x-axis, and then
this-- the square root is,
since it's a function, it can
only have one value, so we
assume it's defined as the
positive square root.
So if we were to graph that,
it would look like this.
Something like that, where this
would be minus r and that's r.
So if we want to find the
volume of a sphere with radius
r, we just have to rotate this
function around the x-axis.
This is the x-axis,
that's the y-axis.
So let's see what we can do.
Let's just visualize
the disks again.
So let me make a disk.
So let's say that that's the
side of one of the disks again,
and as we know, the depth of
the disk is just
going to be dx.
That's how wide
that disk is, dx.
And its radius at any point is
f of x, and in this case, it's
y is equal to square root of
r squared minus x squared.
So what's the surface
area of each disk?
What's this?
The surface area of
each of the disks.
I hope you know
what I'm saying.
So area is equal to pi r
squared, the radius at any
point is equal to this, radius
is equal to y which is equal to
square root-- and remember,
this is not this r.
This is the radius
of this disk.
I know it might be a
little confusing.
y is equal to the square root
of r squared minus x squared.
So the area is going to equal
pi times this squared.
So if you square this quantity,
you just get rid of the
square root sign, right?
So pi r squared minus x
squared, and that's the
area, and so what's the
volume of that disk?
Well just like we've done in
every video up to this point,
the volume of that disk is just
that, so the volume of that
disk is just this pi r squared
minus x squared times dx.
And so if we want to figure out
the volume of all these disks,
I have a disk here, a disk
here, going around and around
and around and around and
around and they get smaller and
smaller until we have a sphere.
We just take the integral, the
upper bound is positive r, the
lower bound is minus r, and we
take the integral of
this expression.
pi-- let me distribute it,
because that's going to make it
easier-- pi r squared, which is
just a constant term, minus pi
x squared, all of that dx.
So what's the antiderivative
of that expression?
The antiderivative
within the parentheses.
Well, this is just
a constant term.
pi r squared, that's just a
number, because we're just
taking the integral
with respect to x.
So the antiderivative of pi r
squared is just pi r squared x,
the derivative of pi r squared
x is just pi r squared, minus--
and we did this in
the last video.
Actually, well now, it's the
antiderivative x squared, which
is x to the third over 3, and
the pi is just a constant, so
pi x to the third over 3, and
we're going to evaluate
that at r and minus r.
Let me erase some stuff, looks
like I'm running out of space.
Hopefully all of that
you know by now.
OK, back to the pen tool.
OK.
So let's evaluate it at r.
So this is pi r squared, and
then for x, we'll substitute
the positive r times r minus pi
x cubed, but now we have this r
here, so r cubed over 3 minus
pi r squared, and then we have
a minus r here, because we're
evaluating the antiderivative
at minus r, times minus r,
minus pi minus r cubed.
So what's minus r cubed?
It's r cubed, but we'll
keep the minus sign.
r cubed, and at that minus
sign, let's just make
that-- that'll turn that
into a plus-- over 3.
Let's see if we can clean
this up a little bit.
So that first term is pi r
cubed, r squared times r, minus
essentially 1/3pi r cubed.
And then, what is this?
This is pi r cubed, but then
we have a minus sign up.
This is minus pi r cubed, and
then we have a minus sign up
here, so this becomes plus pi r
cubed, and then minus-- because
we have a plus here and a minus
out here, so distribute it--
so minus 1/3pi r cubed.
And let's see, what do we have?
We have essentially 1.
If we just distribute out the
pi r cubes, we have pi r cubed
times 1 minus 1/3
plus 1 minus 1/3.
Well that's 2 minus 2/3, or
another way, let's see, is 2
minus 2/3-- this is turning
into a fractions problem-- and
what's-- well, that's 6/3
minus 2/3, it equals 4/3.
So this is equal to 4/3.
So the volume of the sphere is
equal to 4/3 pi r cubed, which
is the equation for the
volume of a sphere.
And actually, now that
I realize, it did take
me eight and a half
minutes, so I am glad.
My first intuition is always
correct, I am glad I did
this in a separate video.
But that should be pretty
interesting to you.
And it makes a lot of sense.
It's going to be a cube of
the radius, pi is involved.
The 4/3 is interesting, just
in terms of how it relates
to everything else.
Area is pi r squared, and then
all of a sudden you get a 4/3
here, so it is something
for you to think about.
Anyway, hopefully
you found that fun.
I'll see you in the next video.